we continue our coverage now the
stunning sexual harassment allegations
against
new york democratic governor andrew
cuomo and his response
let's take a look at how the media are
reacting here's fox news media analyst
and host of fox's media buzz
howard kurtz it was just 16 months ago
that andrew cuomo was riding high
hailed by the media for the coronavirus
briefings that won him an emmy
appearing on his brother chris's cnn
show i've never been prouder of you
than i am right now and being touted for
national office
now there's an official draft cuomo
movement out there to
to try to persuade joe biden to point
him as his vp
with his famous family name the governor
was democratic royalty
a fixture on tv news which cast him as
the rational alternative to president
trump on covid
when the first allegations of sexual
harassment surfaced in february
they were ignored by the network evening
newscast and msnbc and briefly mentioned
on cnn only after accuser charlotte
bennett spoke to the new york times and
went on the air
the governor is trying to sleep with me
did the coverage pick up
cuomo denied the allegations while
apologizing for making anyone
uncomfortable
and once new york's attorney general
began to investigate the story soon
faded
until today by engaging in unwanted
groping
kisses hugging and by making
inappropriate comments
when cuomo denied the findings by
leticia james though he apologized to
charlotte bennett he went after the
press
trial by newspaper or biased reviews
are not the way to find the facts in
this matter
but he asked for the ag investigation
and anchors and pundits were sharply
critical
across the cable news spectrum uh really
devastating for the reputation
of governor andrew cuomo imagine the
twilight zone
these women felt they were working in
essentially normalizing frankly illegal
behavior while at the same time holding
his employees under a thumb of fear
the media are denouncing governor cuomo
over this blistering report and
speculating whether he can survive
the lesson is it's risky business for
the press to downplay harassment
allegations
or portray any politician as a superhero
when he may act very differently
away from the cameras well how i
understand
that you mentioned cnn's chris cuomo
he's actually in this report
that's right investigators found that
chris cuomo in february emailed a draft
statement of denial
to his brother's office saying his
interactions may have been insensitive
that was very similar to the one the
governor actually delivered
and the attorney general confirmed the
washington post report that the cnn host
had also joined damage control calls
about these accusations
with his brother and top officials
shannon all right howard kurtz thank you
very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else